wow
oh wow okay okay like that
[Music]
i'm kristen kish and i'm one of the
hosts of iron chef quest for an iron
legend and i'm esther choi i'm also on
iron chef i'm kevin kreider i'm from
netflix's bling empire not iron chef
not yet not yet not yet today we're
going to be eating some iconic korean
street food from the legendary huangdong
market
yeah nailed that
nailed it okay let's do it
these individual places are all selling
something different or versions of the
same thing so it depends so in the
beginning of the market you'll see a lot
of the things that are similar like
you'll see
like 10 mandu vendors over here which
are all dumplings and they hand make it
you can also get uh hand torn noodles
here as well with soup what's that dough
is that the dough so that's a dough for
the dumplings and also the kargokutsu
which is the
uh noodles oh check it out netflix was
here is this you
oh so beautiful
it's so beautiful
all right let's see what this is like
whoa
wait the soy sauce
okay i'm just gonna sprinkle it
okay here ready so that's kimchi and
this is meat okay so i'm gonna go for a
kimchi dumpling
okay what are you gonna have i'm gonna
go for a meat one
oh wow oh god okay you can eat it like
that
very bright i think the wrapper is
wonderfully chewy i think it's thick
enough because it has to hold up to the
amount of filling inside so you have to
have it structurally sound i think the
acid the kimchi the dumpling wrapper
itself all meld together for one
harmonious flavor you know the the thing
about these mandu in korea is that it
has to be really filled right it's
called together and
that's the beauty of korean mandu okay
let's move on all right okay we love the
dumplings very good but there's a lot
more to see
i mean i feel like the beauty of this
market is that it's so
crowded busy it preserves korean street
food life right which is really
disappearing well i think that's my
favorite part of going to asia just
but you know what it's sad because
they're all disappearing all over korea
they used to be everywhere but now
they're all gone this is a very iconic
korean street food that is essential to
huangdang market can we have one we have
to have those this is something that we
have to have and look at it's called
mung bean pancake so it's mung beans
they add bean sprouts some pork
chives all these different vegetables
and then fry it like this and it's
called
and it's
so delicious because it's so
crispy yeah we need one yeah we're gonna
get one of these so i i just asked her
to make it extra crispy because you know
that's how we like it okay so let's try
this so let's try it
you want you want to dip it in the sauce
you guys oh it doesn't even need salt
does it not need sauce
it's seasoned probably really nicely
what do you think kristen
[Music]
a very reminiscent of a thick hash brown
or like a roasty mm-hmm i got a proper a
proper [ __ ] it's tender just like you
would stick a fork in a done potato it's
like that nice tender resistance just
tastes better than a hash brown i love
it let's move on yeah you want to move
on yeah but take that with us
oh this is something you should see
preston what so it's all the fermented
fish right yeah that's the crab
fermented fish
fermented vegetables all the panchan all
the kimchis
she said she said are you a movie star
yes
she said that she has high standards and
you look like a movie star can i hug you
i love you
she wants to get tips
so this is um really good it's dried
radish that's been
kind of doused in a gochujang sauce is
one of my favorite panchan
oh wow right one fantastic thank you
oh
wait do you like spicy
i do yeah
that is spicy it's not that spicy yes it
is have you had raw crab before never
it's really good is it i would i would
you should have to try it yeah it's
fermented it's not raw
yeah you gotta check out the the meat
okay suck out the meat show me can you
show me so you want to suck because you
got to kind of
use your teeth like a like a pixie stick
just to get the sugar out just bite and
suck
i do want to note
that this is extra special is korean
flower crab
and korean flower crab is a special crab
in korea that has a very soft shell and
a lot of meat and it's a sweet meat
type
so is this are the street food vendors
is this something that a family carries
on and family tradition and each
generation takes over and over and over
again they rotate through different it
rotates because it's what's modern
what's hot right and sometimes some
street food used to be hot that's not
anymore my favorite
um is hot it's just a street food it's
filled with uh
sugar little nuts little sesame seeds
and it's this yeast dough that they fry
into a pancake it's like a korean donut
yeah yeah usually you'll see a lot of
people like older and it's a craft you
know they all they do is make hotel
all day as a kid
this was my favorite and after school i
would run to the hotel vendor and always
get one and eat it on the way home
cheers i like that
[Music]
you know i'm so happy that you like it
why learn artists i know and it's your
first hoof dog experience
i feel special that i'm experiencing
that with you todd's such a hugger come
here
you guys know it's like food is part
of culture so to have food you kind of
experience whole culture all at once and
like having to experience it for the
first time i eat a lot of korean food
but never in korea and never in this
context and to learn about myself by way
of people that know
kind of me better than i know me in a
lot of ways is a really profound thing
to
travel through like you see
you know these people it comes down to
generation
and they're doing it every single day
and the effort that they put in to make
it so perfect
is impeccable and you can really taste
it
[Music]
you